[Musik]
wir sind mal zusammen wir sind ok da
machen wir den schnitt
wir bekommen
erste pläne seien
weil sind ja wahlen in nrw auch sollte
da nicht auch martin schulz
spitzenkandidat werden war den schulz
wird gemeinsam mit uns kämpfen oder
hervorragend hinkriegen in nrw aber ist
so ein toller mann jetzt nichts gegen
dich es geht ja um die partei aber wann
tritt zurück
jetzt geht es um emotionen jetzt geht's
um köpfe vor allem um einen kopf unser
martin da sind inhalte jetzt erstmal
nicht so entscheiden
das glaube ich schon die spd nicht mehr
ab nach hartz iv und co wer also ich
meine die macht alleine ist ja nicht die
qualität auch alleine nicht doch doktor
gemacht sollte auch die qualität für die
arbeitnehmer aber wenn wir gemacht haben
brauchen wir die qualität ja nicht mehr
marina jetzt kann man dadurch offen
darüber sprechen wie schlimm war die
zeit unter dem chef sigmar in dem toll
dass martin ist jetzt macht uns aber
nicht schlimm das ist dieses
stockholm-syndrom von dem man immer so
viel hört wo etwa ein positives
verhältnis zum täter aufbauen
schon 45 jahre mitglied und habe viele
vorsitzenden erlebt aber nicht der
schlechteste
aber er kommt nicht an beim publikum wir
sind ja genau ich fühle mich irgendwie
schmutzig sie als amerikaner wissen von
tram kann man viel lernen
sollte die spd jetzt auch ein bisschen
rassistischer und frauenfeindlicher
werden nur schon mühe polarisiert also
sonst glaube ich niemals womit medien
vertreten das stimmt schon
also ein bisschen
schaust du ernst bist du nicht bei der
spd ich bin gut gelaunt und nicht ernst
schaut dann mag das auch so eine
täuschung sein für die ich nicht also
aber erst gar nicht gerne helfen wenn es
so sagen das ist jetzt gut gelaunt der
gesichtsausdruck das ist für meine
verhältnisse gut gelaunt respekt für die
entscheidung
was ich sagen man muss auch erwähnen ich
habe nie ein böses wort zu dir gesagt
das lag aber auch daran dass sie nie mit
mir geredet hat gesagt weiß ich gar
nicht wer sie sind
endlich ist er weg oder der sigma
doch die folgen mal aus und was ist
jetzt hatte ich da die freude ist echt
und gefühlt eine bitte hätte ich noch
weil ich habe eben wir haben nur ganz
kurz gesprochen
sigma hat behauptet er kennt mich nicht
wir wissen dass es quatsch könntest du
ihm noch diese packung merci geben als
dankeschön für die beste entscheidung
die er jemals getroffen hat seinen
rücktritt
ihr kriegt ja das war sondern sich gut
einteilen wir jeden tag eins und damit
zurück nach köln dankeschön jedoch
[Applaus]
[Musik]